a powerful storm knocked out power
overnight to nearly 1 million homes and
businesses in the Northeast with gust
above 70 miles per hour knock down trees
and power lines heavy rain caused severe
flooding the system is bringing more
strong winds from Maryland to Maine the
Marco Morgan is in ledyard connecticut
where almost 90% of utility customers do
not have power demarco good morning good
morning Charlie we spotted down trees
just like the one that you see right
here behind me rusting on this power
line as crews work desperately to
restore power to the thousands of people
without it the powerful storm battered
the Northeast overnight with whoopi
winds and torrential rain oh it's
horrible outside is flooding all over
when gusts topped 70 miles per hour
across New England and Massachusetts
just north of Boston the strong gust
snapped trees knocking power lines to
the ground on New York's Long Island
crews used two chainsaws to clear branch
and scattered along the railroad tracks
several cars were also crushed some
towns in Connecticut are almost entirely
without power crews worked through the
night to restore electricity and the
most hard-hit neighborhoods
earlier Sunday in New Jersey cars plowed
through flooded streets while others
were loved to strand it in the rising
water and Kearny one woman and her 13
year old son had to be rescued by boat
there are flash flood warnings in Maine
and New Hampshire as the storm continues
making its way north Nora
all right DeMarco thank you so much